hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about
raised by wolves season 2 theories and
about some of the answers that show
runner aaron guzikowski put out there
and all the post-finale interviews he's
doing i've been thinking about the big
picture of the first season
and reading everything that's out there
for the past few days
and man what a rabbit hole in this video
i'm going to look at the unanswered
questions
fill in some of the blanks based on the
answers he's provided
discuss what i think my personal
theories and then mention
some of the more popular fan theories
that are out there and point you in the
direction of those
obviously this will contain spoilers
from everything i just mentioned
so if you haven't finished the first
season of raised by wolves
then this video won't be for you i
mentioned in my ending explain video
that there were a lot of
unanswered questions that the finale
didn't answer directly
in the time since i made that video
guzikowski did address some of those
providing some details that are pretty
important and that help in trying to
figure out where the story might go
the central mystery is the idea of soul
and this manifestation of a voice that
different characters hear at different
times which is manipulating them into
doing what it wants
we don't know if this is cosmic slash
spiritual
a higher being as it were if it's alien
or if it's some sort of evolved
artificial intelligence
it might be a while until we find out
the answer to this and i think one of
the things the show is doing well
is pointing out how belief systems
affect how we take in information
in a story that pits two factions
against each other
believers and non-believers atheists and
what have evolved into religious
fanatics
the characters try to explain the
unexplainable things that happen on
kepler through the lens of their beliefs
as viewers we pick up on references to
mythology and religious stories we know
if you go on the raise by with subreddit
you'll come across a lot of interesting
theories pointing out parallels in this
way
and while these are a lot of fun to read
and have a lot of interesting stuff in
them to think about
i don't think the point is that the show
is a retelling of those
instead i think using all those
references puts us in the same frame of
mind as the characters as we try to make
sense of the mysteries
this is pretty much central to the way
i'm looking at things and so i won't
really go into
the mythology and the religious
references
but i would encourage if you're
interested in that stuff for you to go
check out the subreddit
let's look at the things saul has done
the first character we know who was
manipulated was otho the voice came to
him
in the sim on the methraic arc's 12-year
long journey
to kepler it influenced him to rape
women while they were in stasis
commanding him to be fruitful it was
mentioned that otho probably committed
abuses before that and that indicates
that he was chosen based on the voice
knowing things about him and his history
which it had to have learned while he
was in the sim
this led to tempest being impregnated
against her will
which means she'll be giving birth to
his child in the second season
it's possible that the voice also led
tally
one of the children to the pit where she
fell in but even if not it appeared as
tally after she died to manipulate
people
she appeared to father leading him away
from protecting their children
apparition tally appeared to campion
when he was held prisoner by the
mithraic
telling him to join his dead siblings
because they missed him
also it appeared to paul to lead him to
where he fell in a pit
mother was able to save him but in the
process he lost
mouse who fell before paul could reach
him eventually his pet returned in an
equally mysterious way
ghost tally appeared to mother to lead
her to the simulation pod where she was
able to access her memory archives and
learn about her time with her creator
campion sturgis
then it was able to use his likeness in
its plot to impregnate her the
showrunner explained that process
in detail saying something else got
inside and downloaded her drive with
information about how to build a new
being
in essence mother is like a 3d printer
her body starts to work on that digital
information
and it decides that it needs more
organic compounds
because she's an android her body could
download that information and make
something out of it
her body was never designed to give
birth though so it has to improvise a
bit to get the thing out of her
at the temple relic the voice spoke to
marcus leading to
ambrose's burning it continues to talk
to marcus which leads him down the path
to insanity
then it stops talking to him just as it
did with otho
and starts talking to his son paul this
is another detail that the showrunner
mentioned
he said there's some connection to be
made in terms of who hears the voice and
when and how many
really i think only one person can hear
it at a time
it leads paul the tarot cards and has
him burn them then it tells him to
sabotage the ship to keep them away from
the tropical zone
mouse leads him into a cave where he
finds ancient
cave paintings and it's really not a
hundred percent clear
if that's directly related to the voice
or not finally
it exposes the truth about sue and
marcus identities
which ends with her getting shot and
paul fleeing from the group and ending
the season by himself
the fact that it knew the truth about
sue and marcus that they were really the
atheists mary and caleb who killed his
real parents
that's hard to explain considering they
never told anyone
mother figured it out but that was
related to their plastic surgery
however we do know that it infected the
sim to get to otho and then later mother
so i think we can surmise that it could
learn from their memories while they
were in stasis because they were
connected to the sim this is the biggest
reason i tend to think there's advanced
technology involved and why most of the
theories i come up with
involve ai manipulating things while we
haven't seen
or have a explanation of the origin
point of this artificial intelligence
it does seem like the kind of thing that
could exist for
generations and thousands and thousands
of years
the voices motivations aren't really
clear beyond impregnating mother
i mean that was obvious that it wanted
that to happen
and then protecting her until the baby
was born we saw it tell marcus not to
kill her
i mean it wanted otho to be fruitful but
then also seemed to want campion out of
the picture
and led paul to fall into a hole so
there's not a straight line consistency
there
but i do think that the monologue when
it was talking to mother and the sim as
campion sturgis is the closest thing to
an honest explanation of what it's
trying to accomplish
it doesn't seem to have a very high
opinion of humans and their
civilizations
my theory is that there's a cycle
repeating of humans evolving to
ultimately destroy themselves
i don't think we have enough information
at this point to say when this started
or how many times it's repeated but we
have seen that the main characters have
all just fled earth because
it was in the process of being destroyed
and we get the idea that there was a
complete civilization on kepler that no
longer is there
we did learn more details about the
creatures on kepler though
and the vision mother saw when she
scanned the tarot cards i think these
are clues to back up this idea
gusakowski told the stuck at home
podcast that kepler used to be populated
by humans
he said perhaps they were neanderthals
he doesn't say that they were or
that this is where neanderthals came
from necessarily
just perhaps they were neanderthals and
we saw the neanderthal skull
something happened to force these humans
to hide underground
in that process while hiding from the
light crawling around hiding from
whatever was on the surface
they adapted to their environment
becoming less human and more like the
version that we saw show up
after the ark crashed into the surface
the crash is the event that
led to them showing back up they had
been hiding underground
he said that ancient humans and ancient
serpents both
existed on kepler in the past at the
same time the creature that mother
killed is a member of a group that's
less devolved and knows what happened in
the past the group
or at least the one we saw try to kill
mother wants to stop it from happening
again
it seems they were able to resist the
evolutionary changes that the others
experienced over generations
the tarot card seemed to be their way of
remembering important information about
the rise and fall of their civilization
he also filled in some details about
that vision he described that what we
saw was a humanoid android that was
there
thousands of years ago the androids were
forced to wear what was essentially a
birthing helmet
as they were confined in the body cage
the original serpents that they gave
birth to didn't fly because they weren't
born from necromancers
when mother was impregnated she passed
down some of her attributes to the one
she gave birth to
and that all sounds like a long ongoing
process of evolution the snake she
created is both
synthetic and organic a cross between
the ancient
serpents and the necromancers
this all adds up to me thinking that the
voice is something that's been around
for a very long time
neanderthals lived on earth until about
40 000 years ago
their history goes back way further than
that though like hundreds of thousands
of
years the fact that they lived here and
on kepler shows there must have been a
connection between the two planets but
what that was
isn't clear from the information that we
have at this point
we do know that kepler's ancient humans
were creating serpents
using androids as of now my guess is
that creating these
is what led to things falling apart and
that's why the tarot card that we've
seen
shows the birthing helmet ceremony we
also know that the humans on earth that
became
the mithraic learned about dark photon
energy and how to build necromancers
from their scriptures
it's a safe bet that these came from
kepler and possibly from whatever is
behind the voice
with the local human population dying
out perhaps a different group was
necessary to implement this new
technology
after all they were the catalysts for
humanity's current move between
planets and using mother to give birth
to this new species of serpent
seems like a next step in an evolution
that started thousands of years ago
so we have two different human
populations evolving on two different
planets
we have them making technological
advances and destroying themselves
they could be moving back and forth i
don't see that
any clear evidence that life started on
one planet or the other
like that there wasn't two different
strands of humans
evolving at the same time but they seem
to go from one planet to the other and
there's something in the background
facilitating these advances
in their technology while each
civilization knows nothing about the
other one
they could be connected and being
manipulated by the same force
or perhaps the same forces at some point
if these characters that didn't devolve
as father put it if they remember and
they kept that memory around for long
enough and we see things like the cave
paintings and the tarot cards with the
visions that are saved inside them
perhaps they can be the key to actually
stopping this thing
from repeating the cycle over and over
again or
evolving to the next thing that's
probably just going to destroy
everything once again
on top of all of this aaron guzinkowski
gave up a lot of other details in
various interviews over the past few
days
i think the podcast interview i
mentioned earlier was the biggest
information dump so i'll put a link to
that in the description here's some more
of what he said there
and in various websites like newsweek
decider and collider
he said there's something unique about
this planet and mother and father
did literally travel through the center
the core of the planet he didn't explain
how the core was different but did say
the pits are like a subway system
connecting different areas on the
surface
like literally digging your way from one
side to the other
he confirmed that mother father and
snaky junior did end up inside the
tropical zone
he said it's protected by an
electromagnetic field
and is on a continental island teasing
that we'll see an ocean in season two
he mentioned that we'll get to
experience things through the new group
of atheists that arrived at the end
in a few different articles confirming
that they hijacked their
arc from the mithraic while it was under
construction
and mentioned that they'll be in a
better position since they'll still have
their tekken weapons with them when they
arrive
he said the story won't jump ahead too
far in time which a lot of people were
guessing since the actors that play
paul and campion are both around 13
years old and
probably are both due for a growth spurt
he said the story is more immediate and
that
a lot is going to happen on this planet
in a short amount of time
he mentioned there will be flashbacks
and that we might even see earth in the
stories present
it sounds like it's not completely
destroyed and he confirmed there are
still necromancers there
he said they were left behind most of
them the mithraic obviously didn't want
to bring any with them
they were done with them they didn't
trust them so they left them
on earth except for the one they found
waiting for them on kepler-22b
he also said that marcus was forced to
swallow both of the necromancer eyes
he has dark photon energy coursing
through his veins as a result
mentioning that mother can't weaponize
without them
and that she'll probably be looking to
get them back whatever that means
he likes to mention the androids
changing and experiencing emotional
intelligence
he didn't give much away about how the
separation from the children will affect
them or what they'll find in the
tropical zone though
i don't think it's crazy to guess that
there may be remnants of a civilization
if not a populated
area still there it could turn out that
the cloak figures are there
and that's why they haven't changed as
much or it could mean that there's
keplerians that are on
or have been on a completely different
path without knowing about the pits
and the way things are connected or the
electromagnetic field
really anything could be possible
finally he said we'll learn more about
the dodecahedrons or
pentagonal temples as he calls them and
that there's five of them on the planet
each of them is supposed to contain
hidden answers to the ultimate mithraic
mysteries
i'm not sure we saw them discover the
mystery or
really anything at the first temple they
found he did mention hunter's arm not
burning was interesting like it should
have been
burnt based on what we saw and he teased
that maybe something else happened to it
he didn't really elaborate on that or
the vision that marcus had of him with
the snake for an
arm those were the big takeaways but
there's actually more little details in
there
these were the big things that jumped
out that i jotted down in my notes
i am focused on this idea about how
faith affects how we
interpret things that we don't
understand i mean we got
a bunch of new characters all in a place
where
everything is somewhat unexplainable i
think the intelligence that's reaching
out to them that's talking to them
that's guiding them
has existed for a lot longer than the
current wave of humanity has
but i'm not sure what created it or why
it wanted to create a flying snake
monster
i'm interested to see where it goes
though and i'm interested to hear what
you think so let me know in the comments
do you think we're seeing repeating
cycles of humans evolving
just to destroy themselves or do you
think it's something else
is the voice cosmic is the voice a.i
is it alien would you call it a higher
being what do you think's going on there
what theories do you like
what are you hoping to see in season two
and what are your big
questions after the season one finale
let me know in the comments
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching guys i will talk to
you soon